Grilling is a summertime favorite but no one wants to be the guy that can’t get the grill
started. One of the simplest "mikehacks" you
can use is to light off a handful of potato
chips. Not only are they delicious, they can
be surprisingly flammable as well. But in
this project, you get to keep your snacks
intact, because we're hacking a new breed
of party roasters, and it all starts, with
your empty drink cans.
We’re all familiar with the term “lifehacks” but this summer, the guys at mike’s hard lemonade asked me
to help put a refreshing twist on it with
what they’re calling “mikehacks"
noun: mikehack; plural noun: mikehacks; noun:
mike hack; plural noun: mike hacks
1. basically a lifehack that makes any social
occasion, more awesome.
Now, I just got a tube of chips to start the
coals on my grill. That's pretty awesome,
but they're expensive, and don't burn for
very long. So in this project, let's make
something that's guaranteed to get our fires blazing every time.
These miniature fire starters are simple to
light, amazingly wind resistant, and pack
enough power to get a full sized campfire
blazing, without using any extra tinder. They
also double as a miniature fire pit, just
incase you get the random urge to roast some
munchies. To get started, we're gonna need some empty
aluminum cans, and some corrugated cardboard packaging. Now let's use a pair of scissors to carefully
cut the bottom inch off the can, keeping the
cut as clean as possible. We'll need to do
the same thing with a second can, but let's
make this one a few inches taller. Now check
this out, if we fill the larger can with something
like crayons or old candles, then heat it
up for a few minutes, we should be able to
get the wax to start melting.
That's probably going to take a few minutes,
so in the mean time, let's try cutting our
cardboard casing into smaller strips. The
strips need to be about an inch high to match
the height of the can we cut, and the goal
here is to roll the pieces so tightly, that
they just barely fit inside the can. While
we're here, let's fold another piece of scrap
cardboard in half, cutting a slit down the
middle, so that when it's pushed into the
center of the roll the cut pieces fold out
to the sides like little flower petals.
Alright, it's time to check on the candles, and
you can see they're completely melted now,
and the can is really hot, so let's use something
like a pair of pliers to grip it, and to carefully
pour the hot wax over the cardboard. The cardboard
should soak up the wax, and when the container
is full, let's just set it to the side for
a few minutes, to cool and harden.
Now, you can see here that different sized
cans will make a nice variety of different
sized burners, and if you try removing the
casing after they've hardened, you'll be left
with an amazing mini fire log, that's completely
consumable and won't leave any metal behind
in the fire pit. Now I choose to leave the
casings on, because it keeps the wax from
dripping out as it heats up, and as a result,
these little guys will burn at high intensity
for over an hour. That's more than enough,
to get your camp fires, or stack of coals
roaring. Now these aren't limited to lighting
coals and logs. I found they can make a nice
tabletop centerpiece for backyard parties
as well. I placed a few rocks around the can
for effect, and got an instant micro campfire.
Now that's probably the coolest thing I've
tried all day.
Well now you know how to convert some of your
leftover party trash, into an amazingly versatile
micro fire pit, which will help set the mood
for your romantic evenings, and ensure you
get the blazing fire you need, every time.
The best part is, they're lightweight, dirt
cheap to make, and surprisingly wind resistant
as well.
Well that's it for now. If you liked this
project, perhaps you'll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com